Traductor: Natalia M
Revisor: Luciana Liu
Ésta es Amalia, tiene 82 años.
Todas las semanas debe ir al hospital
por su atención
y esperar, como estamos viendo.
Además, para que la sigan atendiendo,
tiene que dar fe de vida
yendo al banco a cobrar su jubilación.
La última vez que fue se enfermó
porque hacía mucho frío.
Y ahora está esperando
que venga la policía
para que dé fe de que ella está viva.
¿Qué nos está pasando?
¿Dónde quedó la dignidad de Amalia?
Mejor dicho, ¿dónde quedó la dignidad
de todos nosotros?
Que nos la pasamos haciendo
trámites engorrosos,
que nos llevan a peregrinar
de cola en cola
para lograr obtener algún trámite,
algún certificado, algo que nos acredite.
Y nos fuimos acostumbrando a vivir
las cosas de esta manera.
Hacer colas, "el sistema se cayó
vuelva mañana",
"necesita otro certificado",
"lo tiene que ir a sellar",
"demuéstreme que usted es usted".
Y finalmente terminamos acostumbrados,
viviendo esta pesadilla burocrática.
Pero hay buenas noticias,
no todo tiene que ser así.
¿Oyeron hablar de Estonia?
Estonia es el país más digital del mundo
en este momento.
Es tan digital que solamente 3 cosas
requieren ir físicamente a una oficina.
Casarse, divorciarse y hacer
la separación de bienes.
Conocí Estonia por primera vez en 2007
y descubrí un país que había logrado
transformar su burocracia
y hacer realmente fácil
la vida de sus ciudadanos.
El caso es que cuando Estonia
se independiza de la Unión Soviética
estaba tan quebrada que tuvo que innovar
y transformar su burocracia con un
nuevo diseño, pensado en el ciudadano.
A eso yo lo llamo el ciudadano digital.
Y, ¿qué es esto de ciudadano digital?
Es usar los datos del ciudadano de forma
transparente, segura y confidencial.
Para darnos a todos el derecho
de un trato justo e igualitario.
Y esto lo logran resolviendo 4 cosas:
nos piden lo mismo a todos,
seguimos los mismos pasos, nos atienden
las personas correctas,
y toda esa información se guarda
para control posterior.
En todo el mundo se están haciendo
grandes esfuerzos
para mejorar estas piezas
de la burocracia.
Expedientes digitales, trámites online.
Y así todo el mundo cree que
está siguiendo los pasos de Estonia,
pero lamento decirles que no es tan así.
Estonia sigue un camino
totalmente diferente y casi opuesto a
lo que se está haciendo en todo el mundo.
Y vamos a compartir en este momento
algunas de las cosas que yo aprendí
del trabajo que ellos hacen.
Los ciudadanos de Estonia jamás
tienen que volver a llevar
una información al estado
más de una vez.
A esto le llaman el principio "once only",
o una sola vez.
Imagínense no tener que llevar
nunca más la partida de nacimiento
o la fotocopia del DNI para hacer
un trámite. Eso es once only.
Y para hacer esto, hacen algo nuevo que es
hacer que los sistemas se hablen entre sí,
que se puedan hacer
preguntas y respuestas.
Y de esta manera, evitar tener
que hacer peregrinar al ciudadano
entre los distintos organismos
para que vayan a buscar esa información.
Para hacer esto de forma segura
y confidencial
han creado un software que
llaman X-Road. Este X-Road es como
un WhatsApp de sistemas.
Permite que un sistema hable con otro
le pida lo que necesite
y con esa información opere.
Acá lo que estamos viendo
es el monitor de los mensajes
que se están produciendo
en este momento en Estonia.
Hoy es Sábado son más o menos las 20 horas
y los sistemas están trabajando.
Hay más de 1 millón de mensajes,
de intermensajes
o de interconsultas entre
los sistemas por día.
Vamos a verlo un poquito más funcionando.
Cada círculo que están viendo es
un sistema o un organismo
y los rombos son personas.
Vamos a ver funcionar ahora, rápidamente,
cómo los sistemas se empiezan
a comunicar y preguntar cosas,
y el ejemplo que les traigo
es de una persona que va a retirar
sus medicamentos a una farmacia.
Cuando va, el sistema de la farmacia
le pregunta al sistema del médico
si la receta está bien.
El sistema del médico le pregunta al
sistema de la obra social por la cobertura
y si todo está bien, entonces
se produce la operación
y el paciente recibe el medicamento
del farmacéutico.
Dos personas interactuando,
muchos sistemas controlando.
Acá no hay posibilidad de falla,
no hay posibilidad de error,
no hay posibilidad de fraude.
La corrupción no está permitida,
no está contemplada
en esta forma de trabajo.
(Aplausos)
Fíjense, con este pequeño,
con esta pieza digital logran algo
realmente muy fuerte.
En menos de un segundo,
eso que vieron ustedes ahí
tardó menos de un segundo.
En menos de un segundo resolvieron
dos de las cosas que yo mencioné antes.
El trato justo, porque a todos le piden
lo mismo por un lado,
y por otro lado, la información
ha quedado registrada y guardada.
Con ese modelo eliminamos
la posibilidad de tener que peregrinar
entre los distintos organismos.
Vamos a dar ahora por las colas. Vamos a
tratar de ver cómo sacan las colas.
Y para eso usan este concepto de
procesos proactivos, o "push".
Imagínense que nace un bebé. El sistema
del médico habla con el sistema,
y cuando digo "sistema hablando
con sistema" no hay personas,
son sistemas hablando con sistemas.
El sistema del médico le dice
al sistema del registro civil:
"hay un nuevo ciudadano, necesita un DNI".
El sistema del registro civil crea un DNI
para ese nuevo ciudadano.
Pero su trabajo no termina ahí.
Sabe que ese ciudadano necesita
una cobertura social,
entonces avanza un paso,
habla con la obra social y le dice:
"Necesitamos una cobertura
para este nuevo bebé".
Mientras pasa todo esto, los padres
están jugando con el bebé.
Y de esta forma los organismos
se adelantan un paso
creando lo que a nosotros
nos lleva una cola.
¿Se ven? Es imposible hacer colas
con este mecanismo de trabajo.
Entonces, con el principio once only y
con los procesos push
logran resolver estas 4 cosas
que hablábamos antes.
Pero acá no termina la historia, porque
a veces, ustedes podrán pensar
"bueno, y si quiero hacer algo
que no está previsto ¿cómo hago?".
Lo primero que tiene que hacer
es no hacer cola
porque ellos tienen lo que se llama
"mi ventanilla personal",
su ventanilla personal, para que cada uno
pueda ahí realizar lo que necesite.
Acá vemos dos ejemplos de "mi ventanilla"
que como ven son diferentes,
pero ambos permiten hacer
absolutamente todo.
Con cualquiera de los dos
yo puedo entrar a ver mis datos
o hacer trámites con cualquiera de
los organismos del estado.
Solamente tengo que elegir
la que más me gusta,
es como bajarse una
aplicación para el teléfono
y si soy programador hasta me puedo
hacer la mía, no hay ningún problema.
Pero sigamos avanzando,
vamos al control de uso de los datos.
Cuando un ciudadano de Estonia
ve que se están usando sus datos,
porque tiene capacidad para ver
quién está prestando datos a quién,
quién está viendo los datos de quién,
y ve que algo no está normal
que algo no está pasando
como corresponde,
presiona un botón y se genera
una auditoría de lo que está pasando.
Así que es como un gran hermano invertido.
Es el ciudadano el que controla
qué se está haciendo con sus datos,
qué está haciendo el estado con sus datos.
Bueno, después de todo esto ustedes deben
pensar que no se para qué vine a hablar
porque esto es imposible
se hace en los países fríos,
porque allá no tienen nada
que hacer, hace mucho frío.
Y realmente la cosa no es así,
realmente la cosa no es así.
Porque si ustedes están imaginando eso
es realmente porque sienten que
lo que estamos haciendo acá
va para otro lado.
Y les voy a decir que vamos al
gobierno digital, para allá;
y ellos van al ciudadano digital,
para allá.
Es totalmente opuesto y eso es
lo que quiero transmitirles.
Pero yo estoy acá hoy para decirles que
esto se puede hacer acá,
lo hemos hecho acá,
lo estamos haciendo acá.
En Neuquén se está usando
desde hace varios años este modelo.
Claro que primero tuvimos que entender
y comprender estos principios
que yo les estoy contando.
Tuvimos que adaptarlos para
poder adoptarlos a nuestra cultura.
Y finalmente tuvimos que abrir un camino
nuevo de cómo aprovechar estas cosas.
En 2008, cuando empezamos,
hasta hicimos un clon
de ese famoso X-Road, ese WhatsApp
de sistema que yo les comenté.
Con ese WhatsApp pretendíamos
hacer lo mismo que hacían ellos:
evitar el peregrinaje.
Pero mientras en Estonia con eso alcanzó,
dijeron "hagamos esto"
y todos hicieron caso.
Acá no pasó lo mismo, acá cada uno
siguió haciendo la suya.
Entonces tuvimos que inventar
piezas nuestras,
piezas que no necesita Estonia,
para poder lograr el mismo resultado.
Fíjense, si yo logro que
los sistemas se hablen entre sí
ya tenemos resuelto el problema.
De un lado están los datos,
del otro lado está el sistema que
consulta los datos del otro sistema.
La parte de los datos es bastante fácil,
la parte de que el sistema pregunte
es más difícil,
y acá se nos empezó a demorar eso.
Cada día era más lento el desarrollo
de las aplicaciones modificadas.
Por lo tanto, decidimos que
no podíamos esperar,
porque hacer esperar
a que todos cambiaran sus sistemas
para poder beneficiar al ciudadano,
nos hacía esperar a terminar todo
para que el ciudadano se diera cuenta.
Entonces creamos un portal,
un portal que es capaz de hablar
con las bases de datos de
todos los sistemas.
Y de esta forma un funcionario, cuando
alguien se presenta en una ventanilla,
para en lugar de decirle "tráigame
el certificado de esto", "tráigame", no.
Directamente él entra en este portal
y puede consultar en línea
todas las bases de datos
de todos los organismos para saber
si el ciudadano que está ahí
cumple o no con los requisitos.
Con esta pequeña pieza tecnológica latina,
neuquina, pudimos alcanzar
la misma performance sin tener que
resolver todos los sistemas.
Y acá viene una paradoja y esto es lo que
empieza a mostrar que no es lo mismo
lo que se está haciendo con
lo que ellos hicieron.
Para hacer todo esto no hace falta
modificar los sistemas actuales,
hace falta crear las cosas que hoy no
se están creando o no se están haciendo.
Acá tenemos el ejemplo de cómo se produce
un certificado digital virtual
sin que el ciudadano tenga que peregrinar.
Nunca más papeles en la calle,
nunca más llevar un certificado.
El ciudadano recibe los beneficios
instantáneamente.
Por supuesto, en paralelo, y con otras
velocidades y cada uno a su tiempo,
va conectando sus sistemas para no tener
que usar ni siquiera este portal.
Veamos el impacto. En 2017 uno solo
de estos trámites, con este truco latino,
ahorró 108 años/ciudadano, una vida.
Por supuesto repartida entre muchos,
¿verdad?
Y ahorramos también una columna
de resma de 200 metros de alto de papel.
(Aplausos)
Pero el mundo sigue avanzando, Estonia y
Finlandia empezaron a trabajar juntos.
Estonia creó el modelo, Finlandia lo
adoptó. Pero no es usar lo mismo.
Eso que yo les mostré antes de
la farmacia. Una persona que vive
en Estonia, que se atiende en un hospital
de Estonia puede ir a Finlandia
ir a la farmacia y retirar su medicamento
como lo vimos, exactamente igual.
Eso es lo que ellos han logrado.
Por supuesto, cuando hacen esto
también liberan el código de ese
famoso X-Road y lo hacen libre
para que cualquiera lo pueda usar.
Hoy muchos países del mundo
están probando.
Los azules lo están usando, los rojos lo
están probando, los amarillos
están estudiando si vale la pena,
los verdes están operativos.
Neuquén como si fuera la pieza
de un lego, de un juego de lego
cambió rápidamente parte de lo que había
hecho, ese famoso clon, por el de Estonia.
Y hoy figuramos entre los actores
que están usando operativamente el X-Road
(Aplausos)
No me cabe ninguna duda que esto es
factible de hacer aquí.
Tenemos la experiencia local, tenemos
las herramientas disponibles,
tenemos una ruta transitada que
nos permite decir "esto se puede hacer".
Pero tenemos algo mucho más importante.
Ya hace tiempo alguien, un argentino,
había escrito que esto era factible
y ese fue Quino.
Quino nos muestra en esta imagen
lo que es la burocracia, la famosa
cola de la burocracia, ésta es la cola.
Los ciudadanos haciendo cola contra
el gobierno, y él en su poder de síntesis
demuestra que la solución
para la burocracia es dar vuelta la cola.
Bueno, entonces ya tenemos antecedentes,
tenemos historia, tenemos que hacerlo
no hay más excusas.
Yo me comprometo realmente
a seguir avanzando para recuperar
esta dignidad perdida, para que ni Amalia
ni ningún argentino, ni latinoamericano
tenga que seguir padeciendo
esta burocracia que no se merecen.
Y yo les dejo una pregunta, cuando
recuperen esta dignidad perdida
y ya no tengan que hacer más cola
¿qué van a hacer con el tiempo libre?
Gracias.
(Aplausos)
(Música)